you think about potassium bicarbonate. So potassium bicarbonate, what is that?
So you've heard of sodium bicarbonate, sodium bicarbonate is sodium with a carbonate
bicarbonate atom attached to, which is HCO3. And so potassium is a potassium
um, um, atom with bicarbonate attached to it to make a potassium bicarbonate molecule.
So what would be the benefit of taking bicarbonate? So you can read all sorts of
cancer things to using baking soda. I know I'm gonna take baking soda. There's a video of a guy
making baking soda with honey and he dissolves it in honey and he takes that every day,
thinking that the baking soda is gonna attach to the honey and now it's gonna go into the cancer
as baking, as baking soda. And the idea is that you're gonna alkalize the cancer and kill the
cancer by alkalizing it. Okay, so potassium bicarbonate would be an alkalizing agent, sodium bicarbonate
would be an alkalizing agent. Um, but what is it gonna be alkalizing if you swallow potassium
or sodium bicarbonate? It's gonna alkalize your stomach. So let's, we got to kind of take a
step back again. I've talked about this a lot in the past, but I just want to go over it again.
You've heard it said maybe we don't hear it quite as often now, but back in the days we used to hear
this all the time that cancer is acidic and cancer can't grow in an alkaline environment. That was
a huge thing that alternative cancer doctors used to tout and then we need to alkalize ourselves.
And then um, they came up with these, the pH strips and you could test your saliva to see if your saliva
was alkaline or acidic and you could test your urine to see if that was alkaline or acidic.
And then if it was acidic, all goodness, that means you're gonna die or get sick or something that
would be infecitious. I apologize, but then we have to alkalize ourselves. So we take alkalizing
things. We could take sodium bicarbonate. We could take potassium bicarbonate. We could, um,
you know, do other things to alkalize our tissues and then over time we measure our urine or
measure our saliva and oh, we're getting back into range. We're getting our pH is getting better.
Um, and, and that means my, that my body systemically is more alkaline and I'm going to be healthier.
And there's books written about this and there's courses that talk about this. Um, but
I don't want to insult anybody, but this is absolute nonsense. It doesn't make any physiological sense.
So let's think of the physiology. So in our body, we have a pH of our body. We have a pH of our tissue.
You have a pH of your blood that is the most important thing. The pH of your blood has to stay
within a range of about 7.2 to 7.4. It has to or you'll die. If it's out of that range for any given
period of time, you will die. So you have what's called a buffering system. So your buffering system,
there's actually multiple buffering systems to keep the pH of your blood in that range. So this is
where your bones are living organisms. They're not just hard things that hold up your body. They're
living organisms where minerals are going in and out of the bone constantly. That's the danger of
taking those drugs like zometa that actually put a like a like a sulfate wrap on your bones and
create a hard riddle perioste of the outer layer of the bone and don't allow the minerals that are in
the endoste of the inner part of the bone to be transferred in and out of the bone to help
buffer your body and keep a good acid base balance in your blood especially.
Now back to cancer is you know acidic and it's it's can't live in an alkaline environment. Well,
that's just not true. Cancer any cell that's in rapid replication is going to give off a lot of waste
and that waste usually is going to be acidic. So I would agree that cancer can't cancer itself
can be acidic, but it's not growing because the environment is acidic. It's growing because something
got inside the cell and damaged the nucleus and caused it to go into rapid replication. It's nothing
to do with the it was acidic in that area or something previous. It has to do with something damaged
to the cell. So then as it rapidly replicates and rapidly replicates cells that are rapidly replicating
it's producing waste and that waste has to be excluded outside of the cell membrane. It goes into
this matrix of what's called our extra outside cellular matrix. So this extra cellular matrix of
waste is acidic that goes around to cancer and would it be good to alkalize that? Yes. In fact,
Dr. C. Machini from Italy experimented with sticky to needle into someone's tissue right next to
the cancer with sodium bicarbonate to try to alkalize around the cancer, but he wasn't trying to alkalize
the cancer to by changing the environment that the cancer's in the cancer is going to stop growing.
He's alkalizing the cancer so that your immune system can get at it to kill it because that's one of
the reasons why your immune system your T cells and your natural killer cells aren't able to kill the
cancer is because they can't get at it because of this waste. So that's why it's important to your
lip system to support your detoxification pathways because your lymphatic system has to carry that waste
back into the venous system and then through your liver and into the toilet. So taking potassium
bicarbonate or sodium bicarbonate orally is going to alkalize your stomach. Well, your stomach
is the only spot in your body that absolutely positively needs to keep a pH about 2.0 on a scale of
0 to 14 in an acid-based scale. So middle neutral is 7.5 acidity is lower. You need to have a very
acidic stomach. So I think one of the worst things a person can be doing is taking, baking soda,
taking excess potassium bicarbonate thinking that they're helping kill the cancer.
And the last you had a stomach cancer, I don't think that's a very bad thing to do because you're
going to you're going to alkalize your stomach and you're going to set up yourself for all sorts of
indigestion issues, leaky gut issues, H. Pylora is going to grow like crazy. You're setting yourself up
for a world of cold, cold morbidity hurts if you do that. So I'm not for taking potassium bicarbonate.
Now, I will say if you study my chronic disease and autoimmune course, there is a treatment for somebody
especially with Hashimoto's, it's common with Hashimoto's, but it can become with some other autoimmune
issues is that the person can have a member with autoimmune issues, salt, sodium chloride can be a
trigger and sodium and potassium have a balance in your blood. So remember when you have looked at your
comprehensive metabolic panel, one of the things that it measures is your sodium and your potassium
and you want that ratio to be good, you don't want you don't want excess potassium, you don't want
excess sodium. Matter of fact, if the person doesn't have excess potassium and low sodium,
that's typically a sign of dehydration. But one treatment for somebody who's sensitive to
sodium because it's some autoimmune diseases, especially Hashimoto's can have a sodium sensitivity.
So that can be a trigger in the person's autoimmune disease. So if they eat foods with sodium,
then it's advised that they eat take potassium with the sodium, doesn't have to be bicarbonate,
but it has to be a potassium with the sodium. So that's a different whole different thing we're talking
about with that than we're talking about taking potassium bicarbonate for cancer. So I hope that
was understandable, but potassium bicarbonate for cancer is going to alkalize your stomach, set you
up for a ton of possible cold momentities, including the rampant H-pilora issues. So I'm not a fan of
sodium bicarbonate or potassium bicarbonate for a cancer therapy.